oh he got the memo on the jacket he got  the memo on the jackets sessile B  deMille Award that's a lot that's a lot  you know who was the first recipient of  this sessile B deMille Award no sessile  be Charlie's is presenting it to you she  just came down and she was so excited  but she's a little nervous  I met Charlize I think she had been in  one other film that had not yet come out  and she was literally the first audition  that I had to try to cast a movie called  that thing you do and we all we all  stumbled out of the room and just said  that lady is going somewhere I have a  feeling I'll be back presenting this  sessile B deMille Award to Charlize in  another couple of years  you guys go they got you guys got to go  or else there could get going they will  have to they wrap this up I look can we  take a picture together in our jackets  can you get this shot of this jack  [Music]